what happens here okay for starters you
need to remember what's the right
shortcut to use okay and some of us are
confusing which ones you're supposed to
pick right so
when you look at this one right which of
the laws does it match most closely and
the answer is
number five very good
so therefore what i ought to do with
this these two fives
is i should
multiply them 25
which gives me that okay now
let's just think about this for a second
right
before we look at what this number is
okay let's think about another very very
similar number okay this is an 11
suppose we wrote down instead
a 10.
okay now 10 to the power of something is
a really really common thing you'll see
and with good reason i'll show you why
in a second
let's think about this what's 10 to the
power of 1
is just 10
right what's 10 squared
it's a hundred what's 10 cubed
it's a thousand and then ten to the four
will be ten thousand and ten to the five
will be a hundred thousand
and on and on and on so here's the point
right
if you have 10
with
a 2 is the power you'll have two zeros
if i have 10
with a power of 25 then i've got 25
zeros that's a really big number
right
now if 1025 is a very big number
11 to the 25 is going to be even bigger
in fact it's going to be so big your
calculator will struggle with it let's
have a look
11
to the power of 25
it's so big
the calculator can't put the whole
number on its display
okay because you have a look at this
with me we can just count it up actually
let's see one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten ten digits but we
just established it's going to have at
least 25 in fact it's going to have at
least 26 because that one we didn't
count the one okay so it doesn't fit on
there so what it does is it tries to say
well
i can't write the whole number but this
is how big the number is have a look at
this
this is what we call scientific notation
it's one 1.08
et cetera et cetera et cetera right
multiplied by
10
with 26 zeros after it it's a very very
big number right so if i could write
this out if i had a calculated screen
it's big enough right this number would
be i don't know what's the same it'd be
uh
108 million million
million
million
million i think we're ready
might have lost count of how many
millions there are in there but the
point is the number is too big for the
calculator to display you know it's that
big okay so it uses this scientific
notation which we're going to look at in
more detail over the coming years
to express what that number is
question
oh it clearly says under one
right you plus look times let's say why
is it
right now fight 11 to the power of five
five now why is it 25 okay so let's come
back
so i can do this two ways number one i
can just go back to the laws
and you can see this is not looking like
law number one
this is looking like normal number five
something that would look like one of
them would be something like this uh
let's put down here 11 to the power of 5
times 11 to the power 5. that looks just
like
shortcut 1 and so you add those powers
together and you get 10 right
but in fact what we have is this now if
i wrote this out in long form if i
didn't quite get why the shortcut gave
us what it does i'd write this out
see that
it means
whatever's in here
multiply five times right well just so
happened this is what you've got
five times i'm going to run out of space
just okay
so now now that it looks like this
rule one takes over law number one right
these are all numbers of the same base
i'm multiplying them so when you
multiply numbers with the same s what
did you do to their powers
you add them right so be eleven plot
type to the power of five
plus five plus five plus five plus five
which is
25 okay so it's a different scenario i'm
doing different things to this number
versus these numbers okay and that's why
does that make sense